the Joe Rogan experience I can't handle
self-driving cars I can't do that I
can't no I'm not am i yes I am
goddamn how can you die self-driving
cars are real they're here and they suck
right now because they're kill a couple
of people that's insane
there's like five of them on the road
and they've already killed someone them
on the road yeah no I feel extremely
unsafe about that I reject that with
every fiber of my being I Drive my own
car good for you kind of car you drive
Mercedes do you rich chick I'm here
partying we're getting deep we're going
deep I think they'll get it down they'll
get the autonomous car down the real
problem is gonna be the thrill and the
excitement of freedom just getting in
your car turning the key and just going
I'm good
you can't do that anymore that's gonna
that's gonna be a real thing that's
gonna be one day no mmm I mean that
feels extremely threatening as an
American I feel like America to me is
about big long roads and freedom yeah go
where I want when I want kind of thing
yeah if you've got the goods you can
start a business there or whatever it is
that's me as America is the I don't want
to be locked into little channels going
all 20 miles an hour you know like I
need you want to be able to accelerate I
consider driving kind of an art form
it's kind of an art thing it's like a
sport you do an activity and I don't
want to relinquish that to be like a
thing on a factory line well you might
get lucky and die before it becomes
meritorious no no no that doesn't
dovetail nicely with my idea that
they're gonna discover something that
lets me live 500 years because I've
decided that's exact perfect lifespan
for 500 for me personally not for
everyone what do you think that you'll
still be getting after it when you're
like 450 years old
they'll have they'll have hormones for
that they'll have everything you don't
have everything for that have you juiced
up my physical envelope we'll be okay
it's psychology can you not go mad you
might go mad well it depends on if
everyone else is living five hundred
years we have this conversation before
we're talking about if you
found out that you were going to live
this life over again every time like
infinitely would you be able to handle
it no but why you handle it now you
living right now
no would you be conscious that this is
your fifth time we take someone's word
for it back to the matrix Neos come back
like five times he's still keeping it
right right but if someone came up to
you right now and said Liz I'm gonna
give you the reality of existence the
reality of existence is you will do this
life an infinite number of times until
you get it right you're never gonna get
it right so just gonna keep living this
life over and over again hopefully
[ __ ] up less and less each time but
most likely you gonna still [ __ ] up and
just gonna keep doing the same thing
you'd be like no [ __ ] way but if
someone says do you want to end your
life right now he's like no I love my
life when you're on that plane and your
whole body was shaking you're like I
want to stay alive I don't want to die
so why don't you want to stay alive and
just keep doing it over and over and
over No well is there transcendence is
there a goal if there's a goal I can get
with it mmm so transcendence meaning we
avoid hogs day you know that wonderful
movie for me um you gotta watch some
other movies in but I loved um 90s 80s
movies I liked a lot of them - there's
onra that I really like I mean like
Blues Brothers might be top five easily
for me Christmas vacations good movie if
there's something that you evolve into I
can live my life over many times and
strive to be better at it but if there's
no point to it all and I just have to
keep living over and over and going high
school again and again and again oh well
don't you think that human beings
overall are evolving yes I think so I
think even besides I think even our
trials and tribulations and the things
that go sideways they reveal sideways is
an option to us and gets us back on
track
I have an expression that my mother
loves onward and sideways that's good
kind of gets you up in the morning with
your like I can't do it anymore
you know I like that and I like the idea
of I'm very into as
we sort of evolved speaking of UFO
conferences I was driven in the back of
Rick Rubin's Bentley when I first moved
to LA my friend Nora was friends with
him and he drove us to a UFO conference
and I just remember sitting in the back
of this huge Bentley and he wouldn't
talk to me like I was like not of
interest enough to I kept sort of poking
my head up to the front seat to like try
to contribute to the conversation like
no he just like ignored everything I
said and they were talking about the
evolution of human consciousness at this
crazy UFO conference it was pretty funny
it was very organized it's just like any
like name or something it's like
anything yeah they have some good ones
you know there's a business in it though
that's the real issue with all the UFO
stuff is that there's a business is that
you get to a point where people realize
you could you make a lot of profit if
you just start talking about UFOs or
talking about extraterrestrial invaders
that are inevitably coming and when and
and then everything gets murky it's just
it's not always pure you know like
there's some people that look at it and
that are like real researchers like
there's a bunch of them that try to
figure out what the [ __ ] is going on and
they make a lot of sense you know and
they're trying to figure out but they
don't they don't point to anything in
particular and say this this little
fetus this is an alien baby and we're
gonna genes to prove it like you know
they found that little baby to thinking
with the big head just a baby
just deformed baby but what they're
really looking for is aerial phenomenon
right that's aerial phenomenon is one
but phenomena the problem is not
phenomena phenomena phenomena the
problem is we don't know whose stuff
that is right if it's ours it's flying
around they don't tell you about it if
it's some drones the government's
working on that kind of maneuverability
why aren't they using it
what kind of maneuverability you're
convinced they have they can
move great speeds at odd angles is what
I understand yeah I don't see us I mean
they couldn't yeah well here's the thing
they couldn't get here unless they were
able to actually like tesseract what is
that word
tesseract from wrinkle and time you out
now rights moving I haven't seen the
movie but nice like get my box set
[Applause]